الرحيم ارجع اليهم فلناتينهم بجنود لا قبل
لهم
بها ولنخرجنهم منها اذله وهم
صاغرون صدق الله العلي
العظيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين حمدا حتى يرضى فينصر بحمده عباده
الصابرين
الشاكرين وصل اللهم على معلم البشريه
الجهاد والثبات
ابي القاسم
محمد صلى الله عليه واله وسلم ثم اما
بعد يتواصل العدوان على شعبنا لليوم
السادس عشر بعد
المئه بقصف بربري همجي من البحر والبر
والجو ولا زلنا بفضل الله
تعالى عند وعدنا وعهدنا لشعبنا الصابر
الجبار اقوياء
اشداء اعزاء
كرماء ونحن والله يشهد نشعر
بمعانات ونقدر حضوركم وثباتكم يا تاج
الرؤوس وعماد كل تحد
واصرار فسلام الله لكم
وعليكم واجركم حتما ليس على
بشر انما على الله
ومن وقع اجره على الله فاز في الدنيا
والاخره يا جماهير
شعبنا ويا من تبقى من الاحرار في
العالم اننا وفي هذه اللحظات
العصيبه ومن وسط المعارك والمعاناه والله
شاهد نؤكد على ما
يلي
اولا نعلن عن مواصله التصدي
والكفاح امام اله البطش
الصهيونيه في كافه محاور التقدم بقطاع
الحبيب فيا شعبنا الابي الشجاع
المقدام ان ابنائكم المقاومين في رايا
القدس قد نفذوا عمليات جهاديه
مباركه انتقاما
لكم ودفعا لعدوكم النازي
حيث اعلنا بفضل الله تعالى عن سلسله
عمليات
مباركه منها القنص والكمائن
الهندسيه والاستحكامات المدفعيه المحكمه
في محاور غزه والشمال وخان
يونس وبعون الله
تعالى استهداف خطوط الامداد والدعم
اللوجستي لجيشهم المسخ شرق زبال والمنطقه
الوسطى واسقط بقوه
الله عددا كبيرا من طائراتهم
المسيره على امتداد محاور
القطاع جانب عشرات بالمئات عمليات القصف
المدفعي
والصاروخي لمواقع وتحشد
جنودهم وانما نعلن عنه من عمليات بطوليه
ليس لرفع المعنويات او
التفاخر انما يحمل دلاله
عسكريه ورسائل وصلت للعدو بمداد من بارود
ونار وكسرت معنويات قادته قبل جنده والله
خير
الناصرين
ثانيا ان فكره النصر الصهيوني على قوى
المقاومه في قطاع
غزه بدات تتلاشى شيئا
فشيئا ولعل ذلك بدا واضحا جليا في كبنات
الحرب الذي لا يرقى ان يكون مجلسا قرويا
في احد
البلدات فابشروا يا اهل غزه ان نصر الله
قادم والبشري من الميدان وما
نراه وكفى بذلك برهانا
ودليلا
ثالثا ايها الارعن مجرم الحرب
نتنياهو ان تهديداتك
الفارغه بمواصله الحرب لم ولن ولا تجدي
نفعا وباي جيش ستواصل حربك يا
نتنياهو بالجيش المهزوم
المازو المصاب بالامراض النفسيه
المعديه ام بالجيش الذي لا يجيد مواجهه
الرجال في الشجاعيه وخان يونس والشيخ
رضوان وبيت حانون
والوسطى وكل بقاع قطاعنا
الحبيب ايها المجرم
الدجال كد كيدك واسعى سعيك وناصب جهدك
فوالله لن تميت عزمنا ولن تمحو ذكرنا ولن
يسقط عنك عار افعالك في قطاع غزه ما جمعك
الا بدد وايامك الا عدد ونحن باذن الله
اهل الحرب والنصر وانتم
الخاسرون
رابعا
واخيرا لازلنا نؤكد للعدو الصهيوني قياده
ومستوطنين
التامين في سرايا القدس والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه اقسمت
بالله لو فتش جيش العدو رمال غزه ذره
ذره بما فيها رمال بحرها
ايضا لن يعود
اسراكم الا بقرار من
المقاومه شئتم ام
ابيتم
ختاما نوجه تح حيتنا الى رديف مقاومتنا
والسلاح الاخوه في حزب الله
الاحرار واليمن الابي الشجاع
المقدام ومقاومه العراق
الباسله وكل من حذى
حذوهم والعتب الكبير
الكبير على دولنا العربيه والاسلاميه
انظمه
وشعوبا ماذا ستقولون لله يوم العرض
الاكبر كنا نصوم
ونصلي وتخاذل عن نصره
فلسطين ان حسبنا
الله هو مولانا ونعم الوكيل والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته